john vocês sabem qual era o sonho dessa
criança
nascido de pai pedreiro e não é
costureira no interior paulistano
ele sonhava desde criança ser cientista
eu sou muito tímido
gostava muito de ficção científica em
ciências matemática matérias correlatas
tinha grande facilidade com com máquinas
com coisas e que por conta dessa
habilidade na hora como adorava a
ciência era costumeiro ganhasse as
feiras de ciências da sociedade né as
chamadas pelas ciências tanto do
município quanto algumas regionais e na
sua jornada como era a de família muito
muito é humilde am
ele não tinha recursos pra comprar os
componentes e os equipamentos para os
seus projectos que a cada feira de
ciência ele se tornavam cada vez mais
sofisticados e para resolver seu
problema ele conseguiu colocar muitas
pessoas na sua equipe me convencendo a
diretora da escola e professores e assim
né conseguido patrocínio e rateando
custo entre todos nós sabia ele que ele
estava empreendendo ali e aí na sua
jornada a havia sempre uma uma dualidade
entre empreender e criar a eficiência
empreendedorismo e em algum momento essa
criança descobriu que a ciência mais
empreendedorismo é igual à inovação e
essa foi uma um grande aprendizado e fez
com que ele descobrisse que dessa
dualidade
desse desconforto entre uma coisa e
outra ele decidiu ser as duas coisas ao
mesmo tempo e essa criança cresceu e
hoje aqui é a pessoa que fala com vocês
além de trabalhar né com o empreendedor
trabalhar com modelos matemáticos com
equações código inteligência artificial
ah eu gosto bastante de cozinhar e
concepção de conduta ou estressado praça
por sorte da minha namorada ea e também
cozinhando o estudo acaba estudando
muito sobre sobre gastronomia estudando
os grandes chefs do mundo 50 ninguém
chega a seus do software top 50 chefe do
mundo
copiando outros pratos
não há espaço para copycat na alta
gastronomia o que tem a ver isso
será que isso não se aplica também para
as startups
será que a identidade você se reconhecer
como único é não é parte da fórmula para
que você alcance o sucesso 2012
assistindo a uma palestra do haiti meu
sócio e eu a ouvimos sobre o professor
dizendo sobre inovação e
empreendedorismo
ao final da palestra nós perguntamos
para o professor professor
as empresas brasileiras de software
professor conhece e falou olha eu
conheço embraer que do setor aeronáutico
vale mas não conheço nenhuma empresa de
software e nessa nesse momento nós
realizamos que há na não existia uma
empresa de software brasileira e que há
grande a grande conexão se você olhar
para empresas como a amazon google
spacex a o que eles têm de grande é a
sua identidade existe uma forte coesão a
identidade é o que faz a grande conexão
do sucesso dessas empresas
então nesse momento nasceu aquarela que
é uma empresa que busca assim como os
grandes chefs conectar aquilo que é de
mais próximo nem os chefes eles não
no seu no seu dia a dia eles não
produzem eles não fazem cópias da frança
que é o grande referência no começo eles
até usam as idéias produzem mas com o
tempo eles acabam desenvolvendo os seus
próprios pratos baseado em ingredientes
locais baseado muito fortemente na
cultura local e da mesma maneira nós
procuramos embute esse senso de
identidade
da mesma maneira que no ano passado eu
consegui conectar com a minha identidade
que era uma dualidade entre o
empreendedor e ciência a gente não tem
essa idéia na qual nós desenvolvemos um
software que usa a inteligência
artificial ea capaz de juntar uma grande
profusão de dados e encontrar real
identidade deles
descobrindo como otimizar o gasto de
combustível em aeronaves e até mesmo
ajudando as separar com as fármacos já
era o melhor resultado para a cura do
câncer
a ai inteligência artificial esse tipo
de algoritmo tem se tornado cada vez
mais importante para a sociedade
nós vivemos numa nova era uma grande
mudança a mudança em que sai de uma
sociedade e que nós interagimos somente
entre nós e vamos interagir com seres
autônomos nem com as chamadas máquinas
inteligência artificial ea a grande
mensagem é olhando lá de novo traz
startups e olhando para os chefes
o que aqui existe uma grande quantidade
de pessoas estão buscando o seu
propósito
assim como buscar o meu propósito assim
como as empresas precisam buscar o seu
propósito a identidade ela é a única
coisa capaz de fazer com que na hora de
grandes dificuldades você olhe para si e
é somente isso e olhando para si é que
você vai conseguir a força para
continuar a força para o próximo passo
então a identidade ela é o porto seguro
é aquilo que te leva além e aqui como
temos muitas pessoas buscando se
empreender né as pessoas do ted ex mundo
afora observando essas pessoas nas ruas
nas suas vivências nós conseguimos ver
que essas pessoas elas em sua superação
mas elas em algum momento encontraram a
sua própria identidade e aí e aí
conseguiram ir além
é isso obrigado